since we're not now back in Japan and
you know it feels weird actually having
like a weekly schedule but being able to
talk about things that we're not gonna
be releasing like five months in the
future you know it's only it's only like
we're only two weeks behind nowadays
we're talking about current events I can
talk about I can clown on Twitter and it
won't be like horrendously outdated when
this comes up I had a trip to Kyushu
with Chris and uh man people are so
chill in Kyushu I feel like they're
definitely way more chill than up north
yeah I feel like The Vibes people are
just so friendly yeah down south
Miyazaki everyone was chatting every
time I went to a store anything everyone
was very chatty really nice it's just
Good Vibes it keeps you so fun how are
the tourists there I didn't see any
tourists in Kyushu oh okay okay so we we
went to get the um uh doing this video
and we had to go on the bullet train to
get to this point yeah and it
we there was like so didn't see any
tourists in Kyushu yeah I saw like a few
tourists International tourists that
were in
um
in like a a very Scenic Place takachu
Gorge or something what is it takachiko
takachiho Gorge takachiho Gorge uh it's
beautiful beautiful Gorge yeah not
really nice gorgeous there's a lot of
tourists there yeah that was a very big
tourist spot yeah yeah that was in place
I saw Taurus the only other time I saw a
ton of tourists is like I didn't I keep
forgetting this is a huge tourist spot
yeah so we're on the bullet train
no tourists next stop no tourists next
stop no tourists stop and Hiroshima dude
oh yeah dude I I've never seen so many
white people
I've i i as as a as somebody who's lived
here bro I I've never seen that many
white people get on a train at once like
it was like they all there's all the
white people came on single file the
whole time for about like a good like
two three minutes yeah no Japanese
people I was like holy yeah yeah that's
crazy I guess now that I'm thinking
about it you guys came at a time where
it was right before the pandemic so you
guys have an experience like the full
normal Japan I didn't realize yeah a
tourism Invasion a huge of a tourist
destination
obviously I know people want to go and
see the memorials and yeah all the
history behind that but I didn't realize
it was like like I saw more people
getting on that train they did in Tokyo
I feel kind of bad now because
um like we've talked about on trash
tastes so many times like Japan opened
up the borders open up the borders right
and then now that everything's bustling
and everything's like busy again I'm
like man [ __ ] all the tourists man they
ain't the real ones but they don't know
the struggle man the frustration I think
that Ghana has is that it's annoying
when because you look like this and you
look like this and you look like this
yeah everyone just assumes you're a
tourist yeah which is fine but sometimes
you're talking Japanese and then they
refuse to talk Japanese back to you yeah
but like we briefly touched on this last
week and I would like to say as a
disclaimer yes that does make me a
hypocrite
because like I I just realized yeah
there's a few things right some of my
like some some of the spots I used to
like like to go to like and have like a
little bit of peace and quiet and stuff
like that now it's just like overrun
like some of my favorite restaurants
like it's it's
how dare tourists enjoy things it's just
the little things you know now when I
want to go to some of my favorite
restaurants before I was like you like
there was if I wanted to book a
restaurant there was like zero chance it
would ever be full or rejected and how
dare restaurants be like having a
bustling business now and not cater to
my exact needs of when I want to eat
what the [ __ ] is up with so how Japan
how dare Japan finally we have a
thriving economy
I mean obviously very minute complaints
overall I'm pretty [ __ ] hyped that
serious about it feels more alive Japan
but we went to we went to Golden guy
yeah and um golden guy I love golden guy
I feel like it's got a certain Vibe you
can't really get anywhere else so I
think it's a Cool vibe
I mean I hadn't really gone much outside
of pandemic yeah now because most of the
time it wasn't open yeah now I I so I no
I didn't like I'd only really gone a lot
during the later half of the pandemics
it was great because there wasn't many
tourists and it was chilling and I've
been to Golden guy before as a tourist
and I forgot how tourist heavy golden
guy is oh it's a golden guy if you don't
know what it is it's basically this like
I don't know it's it's got like a 100
200 300 some insane amount of bars
packed into a tiny Alleyway system and
it's like there is
tens and tens of bars on like a 20 meter
strap and they all hold maybe like four
to six people Max yeah sometimes even
less yeah and we were there the other
day and oh my God the amount of times
you got recognized it was so awkward
because golden guy's tiny right so he's
like imagine there's four seats in a bar
and then like three maybe like tourists
of fans who recognizes they try and come
in and the owner's like bro what the
[ __ ] there's only one seat get out and
we're like we're like oh oh God no now
we're being a nuisance because people
are trying to come in and sit with us
and it's like no you can't come in
there's only one seat stop stop it's
also it also doesn't help that because
these bars are so small a lot of them
don't have doors yeah people so people
can just kind of walk along and like
look at lots of places yeah and they're
like taking pictures of us from outside
the bars and stuff which is fine like we
don't really care but like we're just
like oh we don't want to be in you since
the lights I feel bad for the boss the
bartender yeah it's more like the
bartender because we didn't want to like
be a nuisance to the bar like a lot of
them are very quiet yeah Chill Vibes
well luckily look the the bar that we
went to the bartender was fine looking
you're having a good time yeah I was
like hell that's hilarious what's that I
actually love going there a lot to speak
Japanese and kind of try and improve my
terrible Japanese so yeah fun for that
but I don't know how much how easy
that'll be yeah it's just it's it's not
so much bad as is just a mentality shift
right because For the Longest Time Japan
had just been the place where you know
you you can just you didn't have to like
think about getting recognized or
something you know you didn't have to
like that wasn't even like a thought in
your mind you're just like oh this is
just normal and now especially going to
like heavily touristy places like golden
guy or other places like that you like
your mentality has to switch to be like
oh I mean anime convention mode kind of
where you know you kind of like we're
ready to take a picture yeah yeah you're
kind of like maybe maybe someone here
will know me maybe not it doesn't matter
it doesn't you know I mean I would still
argue that it's still not as bad because
for the most part you know Japanese
people if it's a full-on Japanese person
like they won't know who you are
again I don't mind it's just different
like it's it's like I said it's just
mentality in general I'm really happy
that things uh feel like they're slowly
being more the city feels alive again
yeah it feels like stuff is slowly yeah
it's crazy to think that it took this
long but like even bars are being a bit
more you know uh being a bit more lively
and yeah a bit more and it's kind of
it's cool to see yeah just how like one
announcement just kind of changed the
game yeah it's it's like I I complete
like I complained last week about you
know taxi drivers you know refusing to
speak Japanese to me but I will say like
a taxi drivers also seem way more
enthusiastic now yeah yeah
they've they've seen way more
enthusiastic and way more like talkative
and stuff like that and yeah I don't
know it seems like not just like the
tourists has reinvigorated the city but
even like the locals you know you go to
the restaurants and you go to businesses
again you know they you know they seem
way more I guess alive there's been a
real big struggle right now because
they're they're short on
taxi drivers now oh really they need
more taxi drivers they need more uh
staff for hotels apparently flights are
like fully booked oh yeah into Japan
because people are just like I'm going
yeah I waited three years yeah and like
you know it's it's pretty crazy now and
but like think about it in one sense
that the biggest
um foreign tourist in Japan is is China
yeah and China they can't leave yet yeah
so it's gonna be so we haven't actually
experienced
this is just the first wave you know we
haven't met the final boss yet this is
phase one of the boss battle guys it's
interesting though I will not I will say
not only are flight prices like tripled
yeah even more in some cases because
they were like they were pretty much
like free yeah uh hotel prices in Turkey
I've noticed I've gone up yeah they've
gone up quite a lot I'm not surprised by
that um like way more than I'm used to
now I have to like recalibrate how much
I think hotels are in Tokyo because the
demand has gone the same yeah
um but they still have quarantine hotels
really do they yeah there's a i because
you can you can tell which hotel is
quarantined because one it's an apple
hotel and two you'll see it's like
cordoned off at the front there'll be a
security guard outside right and they
still have them right and it's kind of
like oh didn't realize we still needed
quarantine hotels I suppose we do
apparently we don't yeah I don't know
interesting yeah but I wonder I wonder
why if the hotels are want that the
government must be paying an absurd
amount of money oh I'm sure these hotels
to want them to keep being quarantined
hotels yeah